Through film and media, we
can learn about empathy.
Empathy is something we
really need right now.
Story and art has the power to
change things in the world
and make the world
a better place.
It's giving people a relief  from
their lives, for a couple of hours.
I think it's up to the
filmmakers to do what's right,
using their influence
for the greater good.
If you have seen
my film, what I'm
really looking for as
generic universal language.
Anyone can watch this film.
And put themselves in
our character's shoes.
And I think that's beautiful.
We are doing this
film to bring change.
This kind of crime should
never happen again.
I want people to look critically
how that these stories are
still going on.
Really looking at
introspectively
and thinking what
is wrong with that.
I wanted the
audience to take away
how they affect the
environment and nature
with a cup of coffee.
What is your role in the world?
To what extent you
have an impact?
And how can you do better?
I want them to ask who
was the real culprit.
I want to raise awareness.
I think what's so
important to me
is to expose the world
to South African stories,
to South African talent.
It will be important for me
to get people to just leave
with an appreciation for
these kids who are far more
resilient and smarter and
have a very real sense of what
life is.
In these times
filmmaking helps us heal.
I don't think
filmmaking is important.
I think it's essential
for our lives.
Welcome, everyone.
I'm David Rubin, president of
the Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences.
It's my honor to introduce
the first ever virtual Student
Academy Awards.
Although I'm hopeful,
as we all are,
that this will also be the last
virtual Student Academy Awards.
Just as inflection
points like the Cold War
and 9/11 shaped the
perspective of past generations
of filmmakers from Stanley
Kramer to Kathryn Bigelow,
2020, a year like no
other, will no doubt
forever influence
what your generation
sees through the camera lens.
And judging by this year's
nearly 1,500 submissions
received from 328
schools from Albania
to Vietnam, what a promising
generation you are.
My thanks go to the more
than 750 Academy members
who volunteered their
time to judge entries
in seven categories
and had the challenging
responsibility of selecting
this year's gold, silver,
and bronze winners.
And now I'm pleased to introduce
someone whose career trajectory
from Mexico City to Hollywood is
an inspiring example of carving
one's own path.
Recently he starred in
and executive produced
Dora and the Lost City of Gold.
Please welcome the host of
this year's Student Academy
Awards, actor, director, and
producer, Eugenio Derbez.
Thank you, David.
Hello, everyone.
Even though I'm the one
on your screen right now,
this night is for the people
who deserve the credit, you,
the nominees and recipients
of this year's awards,
who earned the applause
that we're sending
across the internet to you.
Bravo.
Over time, Hollywood has become
more inclusive, more open,
more accepting.
But we still have a ways to go.
To make it in
Hollywood is not easy.
But however, at its
best, our industry
can be that shining
example that there is
room at the table for everyone.
This year, we couldn't
be on a stage.
But in previous years, we
couldn't or wouldn't do
what just happened a week ago.
We invited this year's students
to be part of a Zoom interview
and asked them how it
felt to be a finalist.
And then, listen, and
then, we surprised them
by beaming in legends
from their fields,
who then revealed the
real news to each winner.
So let's get to
what really matters,
the spectacular artists who
are all winners in tonight's
first category, animation
and international animation.
Every year, the
winners in this field
find mesmerizing new ways
to transform pen and ink
into pixels and plasma screens.
And your new generation
promises to push us
towards farther frontiers.
This year's domestic
animation winners
had the joy of being given the
big news by an Oscar-winning
Disney legend and animation
director of the soon
to be released Over
the Moon, Glenn Keane.
It's a real pleasure to
introduce you to Glenn Keane.
Oh, my gosh.
Hi.
Such an honor to meet you.
Sorry, you're like, my hero.
Thank you, Kate.
Daniela, Chrisy,
Maya, congratulations.
You have won the bronze medal
for your beautiful, beautiful
film, Hamsa.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
It's such an honor to meet you.
Anyway, I'm fighting
back tears right now.
This is amazing.
Our story is about
a little girl.
Her mother tells her to fear
the other or the unknown.
And she soon learns that
actually, we're all the same.
And that there is no
reason to fear each other.
I feel, like, anyone
could watch this film.
And put themselves into
our character's shoes.
Oka, it was a very
meaningful story.
We can change any
generation's mindset.
I think it's very
important to show
different cultures on screen.
Us as a team, we have so many
countries that we represent.
It just proves to you that we
can go past what we look like.
I just want to thank first and
foremost my thesis partners.
I also really want to thank
my family and friends who
knew that I could do it
more than I even knew.
I would love to thank my thesis
advisers, Harry Dorrington
Elizabeth Ku-Herrero
Eric Cunha and SVA
for supporting us through
our journey and difficulties.
We definitely could not
have done it on our own.
I would just like
to thank my family.
I love you guys so much, all
my friends from back home.
Thank you again to the Academy.
This is honestly so amazing.
So thank you.
It's an honor to tell you, you
have won the silver medal award
for beautiful, beautiful
film, Mime Your Manners.
Thank you so much.
It's amazing to
hear it from you.
I wish I could give
you a hug right now.
I'll give you a virtual hug.
Our film is about
an arrogant man that
is transformed into a mime.
And then he has to grow
to be a better person
to be freed from it.
This story was important
to us because we
wanted to tell a
lesson about anger,
and controlling that anger,
and how you want to be treated,
and how you treat others.
I hope this story
resonates with other people
because it's about
the golden rule.
And to show that even
if someone at one point
is hateful and angry,
that they can grow
and to understand each other.
Our film, Mime your Manners
won the Student Academy Award.
Oh, my goodness.
What?
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
I want to thank my mom and
dad, my brother and sister,
and the rest of my family for
being so loving and supportive.
I'd like to thank my older
brother Keith, my parents,
and my family.
And last but not least, my
significant other, Rebecca.
Your film, Ciervo, is
absolutely beautiful.
You have won the gold for
the Student Academy Award.
Thank you so much.
Here you go.
There you go.
Go ahead and take it
My film is Ciervo,
about a young girl
grappling with an abusive,
violent relationship
and also comparing
that relationship
to deer and predator-prey
relationships
in the environment.
What I want people to take
away is an understanding
of the difficult situations
that are portrayed
and feelings of empathy
for a lot of the characters
that maybe you wouldn't
normally have empathy for.
I always feel the best
way to express something
for me is just visuals
and drawings and images,
even if it's images that
don't really mean anything.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
I'd like to thank the
Academy for giving me
such a wonderful opportunity and
giving me this amazing award.
I feel truly humbled
and honored to be one
of the recipients this year.
I encourage people to share
themselves and share their work
and share each other's
work and connect to it
and talk about it.
Be passionate and driven.
As long as you have a goal,
and you're passionate about it,
you can do anything.
Thank you to the
Student Academy Awards
for this amazing opportunity.
And hopefully,
we'll see you later.
Congratulations to
our animation winners.
Also, our international
animation winner
was surprised by the amazingly
talented Japanese artist
and filmmaker who
most recently gave us
the mesmerizing experimental
film, Leaking Life, Shunsaku
Hayashi.
Your film won the gold medal
in the international animation
category.
Congratulations.
No.
No way.
This is not, no,
no, this is a joke.
Right?
Oh, my god.
Beauty won this year's
Student Academy Award.
[APPLAUSE]
Oh.
That's cool.
Congratulations.
Nice, thank you very much.
My film is about
an ironic journey
through a breathtaking
underwater world where
nature and plastic becomes one.
The story is important to me
because nature gave me so much.
It's so important to
keep nature alive.
I want the audience take
away some sensibility about,
can you use plastic?
Hope they change
their mind a bit.
During this production,
I was, like, in a tunnel.
Reaching this unreachable
Oscar is so amazing.
It's like landing on
the moon or something.
Dear Academy, thank you
so much for choosing
The Beauty as a winner.
I want to thank also my
entire team for supporting me
on this crazy journey.
And I also want to thank
the entire Film Academy
Baden-Wurttemberg and the
Institute of Animation.
And last but not
least, I want to thank
my wife and my kids
who give me strength
and hope to wrap
it all together.
Thank you so much.
Bye, bye.
Congratulations to
our animation winners.
I love animation.
I really love animation.
Growing up, I learned a lot
from the great animated films.
Although until I
was 12, I thought
all mice had four fingers.
And now it's time for our
next award categories.
Alfred Hitchcock said,
in feature films,
the director is God.
In documentary films,
God is the director.
In the hands of
this year's winners,
conscience and conviction
worked together
to make a world of
complexity and conflict
just a little clearer.
And that's why it
was so appropriate
that they received their good
news from a groundbreaking
documentarian who most
recently reminded us
of the power of getting
into good trouble.
Yeah.
The film exploring the life
and legacy of John Lewis.
I'm talking about visionary
producer, director, and writer,
Dawn Porter.
I get the honor of telling
you that you have won a medal.
You are the bronze medalist
in documentary in this year's
Student Academy Awards.
Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
I didn't expect that,
Lamya Essemlali is a
French ocean activist.
I followed her
all over the world
trying to protect sea turtles
from being poached and whales
from being hunted.
Her story shows
everything is possible
as long as you follow your
ethics and your passion.
Congratulations.
Whoo.
[INAUDIBLE]
[CHEERING]
We need to savor this moment.
I would like people to
really question what is
my relationship to the ocean.
To what extent the way I
eat can have an impact?
I am touched and so appreciative
that the Academy is helping
your light to shine on
an environmental issue
to raise awareness.
Special thanks to my
family and my parents,
to New York University, to
my very able collaborators,
to my co-workers and supervisors
from Great Big Story This medal
is also a recognition for Lemya
Essemlali's determination.
Thank you from her.
Thank you, Lamya.
I have the honor of telling
you that you are a silver medal
winner in documentary film for
the Academy of Motion Pictures.
Are you serious?
I'm serious.
My film The Dope Years
is about Latasha Harlins
who was shot and killed
right before the Los Angeles
uprising in 1991.
Black in a country
where coming of age
is coming up far too short.
Each flower before me represents
those black and brown children
whose stories were
cut short due to gun
violence and racial profiling
as a result of playing music too
loud, for asking for directions,
and in Latasha Harlin's case,
for buying orange
juice at the age of 15.
These stories are
still going on.
I think as filmmakers,
we should always
strive to not be afraid of
thinking critically and asking
questions.
I am a Christian.
There is this verse that says,
write it out and make it plain.
One of my goals that
I had written out
before I went to USC was to
win the Student Academy Award.
I just recently erased
it from the window.
That was an incredible feeling.
To my producers, Menu'ette,
Andreas, and Marquise
and my Ride or Die 547 team
Fatima, Eka Kevin, Julise,
Derek, August, and Lawford.
To my mom and dad, you
mean the world to me.
This award is dedicated to
activists in Denise Harlins who
never remain silent.
Thank you to Ebony and Naomi
for sharing your lives with me.
Thank you to the USC
school's cinematic arts
for seeing the
promise in this story.
And thank you to the Academy
for this honor and recognition.
This is for Latasha.
I have the honor
of telling you you
are the gold medal winner
in documentary this year.
Really?
Congratulations.
My film is about a
Chinese student Xinran
Li who was beaten to death five
years ago near the USC campus.
And our main subject,
Rose Tsai, she's
trying to fight for his justice.
we are doing this
film to bring change.
This kind of crime should
never happen again.
It's very hard to
remain objective
because I can feel so much
pain with Xinran's parents
and everyone in the story.
That's also why I called
it Unfinished Lives
because I feel for everyone,
their lives is just unfinished.
I feel like the future
of film is in fantastic
hands with artists like you.
Thank you.
I'm crying.
OK.
So I have another news to
announce to all of you.
We are a winner.
And we won the gold medal
in the documentary category.
What?
We did this film to
honor Xinran's life.
And I'm very glad that
people care about the story.
And we got recognized
by the Academy.
I want to thank Xinran's parents
and Rose and Joel and all
the subjects we interviewed.
Not only because they
supported the film
but also what they
did for the case.
They made the story happen.
| also want to thank my
crew and my mentor Amanda.
They are the best crew and
mentor I can ever ask for.
I also want to thank my parents.
Thank you for telling me
that my life is unlimited.
I love you all.
How are you?
I'm good.
It is my honor to tell you
that you've won the gold medal.
What?
You've won the gold medal in
the International Documentary.
Oh, my god.
My heart is beating
so fast right now.
First of all, I would
like to thank Bertha
for even letting us tell her
story, for opening up to us.
My film is about Bertha.
She is an adult now, but
it's about her story,
a child who had been
abused by her own father.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
The film is about her taking
back the power of her own life,
not just a story about
experiencing trauma
and being a victim,
but the power that you
have within yourself to actually
choose not to be a victim,
to choose to stand up.
I wanted to shine a
light on the subject.
I needed to show the
strength of Bertha,
strongest woman I've ever met.
Her story can help a
lot of people in a field
or in a subjects that people
don't actually talk about.
I've kind of fallen in
love with documentary
because you're telling
stories of real people.
And no matter who you meet
on the street or sit next to
on a bus, everyone has a story.
I'm going to say a
sentence that I never
thought that I would say.
Thank you to the Academy.
Bye.
If documentary films
reveal the world as it is,
our next category,
alternative experimental,
invites us into a world as
only the filmmaker can see it.
From Warhol to Buñuel to
Fassbender and Ackerman they,
they dare to make
us uncomfortable.
If John Lewis taught us the
importance of good trouble,
then this year's alternative
and experimental films
share with us the good
kind of uncomfortable.
Shunsaku Hayashi has said
that alternative work
is like traveling alone
somewhere strange,
to get lost, disoriented,
and to explore new meanings.
So I know the
winner was thrilled
when Shunsaku himself was
kind enough to present
the medals in this category.
Your film won the gold medal in
the Alternative or Experimental
category. .
Congratulations
Is this a joke, or is it real?
You are now a Student
Academy Award winner.
Oh, my god.
Our film won the Golden Award
at the Student Academy Oscars.
You guys are all
Academy award winners.
[INAUDIBLE]
You guys are great.
I'm speechless.
[LAUGHS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When I work, I'm truly and
fully led by my imagination
and intuition.
Simulacra as a concept is
mainly about the connection
between reality, society,
and symbolism, and also about
duality.
It's important for the
whole world in 2020
because there are a lot of
serious things happening.
I would want to find a way to
convey this alternative modes
of storytelling.
My film is motion capture,
3D scan, 3D motion graphic,
installations, even
contemporary theater.
I really want to say big thank
you to my mom and my dad.
My parents are obviously
super supportive.
Really want to say big thank
you to all my crew, my friends,
my colleagues, especially
faculty from USC.
I'd like to thank the
Academy for bestowing
this tremendous honor
on our film Simulacra.
Thank you to the Student
Academy Awards for the award.
Thanks so much.
The Student Academy Awards
are the best recognition
you can expect if you
are a student filmmaker.
It's the thing that
everybody wants to win.
It's the Oscars of students.
I don't know.
I keep hearing
the word medalist.
So I guess it
looks like a medal.
Is it like a stick
figure with its arms
out and maybe like wings?
I don't know.
It's hard to describe it.
It's like a box.
I wish the Student Academy
Award would be a small version
of the real Oscar.
Like, a little
student with glasses
on it and a bad haircut, making
this pose, don't have money.
Something like that
would be really great.
The biggest lesson, my
god, too many lessons.
It was exhausting.
Don't animate when you're sick.
Just don't do it.
One of the most important
things that I learned
is to trust your gut.
You know what's best.
It's your story.
Nobody knows it like you do.
Just do it.
You're going to fail, but
when you fail, you will grow.
That I was going to win
a Student Academy Award.
Because it was going to give
me more confidence in what
I was doing.
I wish I knew that the
first cut of the film
was going to be one hour long.
Perhaps, I could have
written a few more scenes.
And I would've made
a feature out of it.
If you fly a drone
very close to a river
it will get sucked down.
And you will lose it.
And it will cost a lot of money.
I recently watched Stanley
Kubrick's Eyes Wide Shut.
There was a guy who had a
totally different idea of how
to wear masks.
It was Kubrick who said a
narrative film should be more
like music than like fiction.
It should be a progression
of moods and feelings.
The theme, what's behind the
emotion, all that comes later.
This year, student
winners take us
inside the moods and
feelings of characters
that command our attention
and capture our affection.
And like the best
conductors, they
lead the orchestra
to a crescendo
and leave us on the edge of our
seats waiting for resolution.
We are hooked.
Let's first hear from our
international narrative
winners.
And let's relive the big
reveal as they learned
they were winners, receiving the
news from the acclaimed writer
and director of last year's
Independent Spirit Award
winning The Farewell, Lulu Wang.
You are a Student
Academy Award winner.
Your film--
What?
Won the bronze medal in
the international narrative
category.
Whoa.
Thank you so much.
I wasn't expecting
this to be, like--
the results right now.
Like my heart is pounding.
When they told me, my roommate
which is also my best friend,
was right next to the door.
I wanted to open it and
just hug her, hug someone.
Because you know, you're
just like in Zoom.
And you want to be with people.
You want to share the thing.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[APPLAUSE]
My name is Marie Mc Court
I went to Institut des Arts
de Diffusion
The name of my movie is I was
Still There When You Left Me.
While her block is
burning, a 7-year-old girl
is consumed with guilt,
thinking she started
the fire of her building.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
What I want my audience to
feel is empathy for sure.
I want them to ask who was
the real culprit of the fire.
It's obvious that it's not
the little girl's fault.
And I guess from what
you see in the movie,
you can find answers.
I'm this girl from Paris,
studying in Belgium,
winning an Academy Award.
It's so hard to process.
But I think it's a beautiful
way to welcome our generation
into the film industry.
And I hope it's going to
inspire girls around me
to believe that they can
achieve whatever they want.
Action
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You are a Student
Academy Award winner.
Your film has won
the silver medal
in the international
narrative category.
No way.
Wow, this is a lot
to process right now.
I mean, this is
a great surprise.
Wow.
It's big.
And I just can't wait to tell
my sisters and my parents
and my teammates.
You know, it's a lot.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
My name is Percival
Arguero Mendoza.
I studied film directing
at Centro de Capacitacion
Cinematografica.
My film is called Crescendo.
Crescendo tells the story of
a young violinist who really,
really wants her
teacher to accept her
into his prestigious
string quartet.
But in the process, she
learns that she really
needs to stay away from anyone
who expects her to do anything
other than playing music.
We'd like to think of Crescendo
as a story of empowerment
in the face of abuse.
We wanted to be part of
that conversation that
was long overdue.
I'm really happy to say
that making Crescendo
was a delight for me and
my whole team, actually.
We're very much in love
with each other, you know.
My team was really there
for me and was really
there for the project.
I would really like to thank
my parents and my sisters.
Of course, I'd like to
thank the cast and the crew.
Last but not least, I'd
like to thank the Academy
for this huge recognition.
The whole team is
excited about it.
You've won a Student
Academy Award.
Your film has won--
Oh, my god.
The gold medal in the
international narrative
category.
Very well deserved
and congratulations.
Well, I need some
second to process this.
Now if I'm going to tell
my team that this happened,
in my school they're
going to all freak out.
Oh.
Bravo.
I'm German Galub.
And I'm from Estonia,
from Tallinn.
And I study in Baltic
Film Media School.
And we did the film
My Dear Corpses,
or in Estonian,
[ESTONIAN] Basically,
talking about young man who is
desperate to get his home back
for his mother.
And he will start to work
as a corpse transporter.
I worked myself as a
corpse transporter.
So I know this work.
And this film is
not autobiographical
or some biopic in a sense.
I just had some experience.
And I thought what
would happen if I'm
going to push it a
little bit further
and tell something important
that I understand personally.
It's a rite of passage.
I tried to give people
opportunity to say
that we are not immortal.
And we have to remember that.
We have to remember what is
human, what makes us human.
That's the most important thing.
I would like to
recognize for my win.
But I wouldn't say my win
because a lot of people
did this.
And they were so
dedicated to the project
and that made a
whole difference.
If it's done from the heart,
then it's done the best way.
On this project worked
over 90 people for you all.
Thank you again, [ESTONIAN].
And now, our final award of
the evening, the 2020 Student
Academy Awards for
domestic narrative.
Just imagine how
thrilling it was
for them to have their Zoom
interrupted by a living
legend, not just of the
Academy but also of the Student
Academy.
Listen, in 1983, the Academy
bestowed a student award
on a 26-year-old for
his master's thesis.
Well, 37 years later, he's
still breaking new grounds
with the Da 5 Bloods.
We were honored that the
inimitable filmmaker and Oscar
winner Spike Lee joined us
to pass the creative torch.
Basically, I'm on this call--
Hello.
Hello, Talia.
How are you?
I'm good.
And then they
asked me, you know,
what it feels like
being a finalist.
It's always a very
romantic idea to be
recognized by the Academy.
And they say to me, we
have a surprise for you.
I've invited a special
guest to join us.
And then Spike Lee pops up.
Hey!
How are you, Spike?
Is this happening?
Is this--
It's not Industrial
Light and Magic.
It's me.
I was like, what?
It's such an honor
to meet you, Spike.
Like I--
Rommel, the honor's mine.
I'm here to tell you,
you won the bronze award.
Wow.
You did it, my man.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
Congrats, Rommel.
That's amazing.
My name is Rommel Villa.
I went to the University
of Southern California.
And my film is Sweet Potatoes.
My film is a historical
film about Luis Miramontes,
the Mexican scientist who
synthesized the birth control
pill.
This story basically focuses
on the religious, personal,
and socio-econoomical
consequences of his invention.
It definitely feels great.
It's a huge honor
to have this win.
There have been
many times where I
didn't believe I was talented.
There are a lot of, I
think, confidence struggles
that filmmakers go through.
So getting this win, it means,
I think it means everything.
First of all, I
would like to thank
God for the blessings
and challenges
that life has given to me.
Thank you so much to my
family, to my partner,
and to my friends for believing
in me, especially when I
don't believe in myself.
This film was made
with the heart and soul
of a lot of minorities who put
their passion into filmmaking.
Congratulations. you
won the silver award.
Oh, my God.
[INAUDIBLE]
I know I got a call yesterday.
And I found out that I won
the Student Academy Award.
What?
Wow.
I'm Kareshma Dube from New York
University, Grad Film Program.
And my film's called Bittu.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
At it's heart,
it's an examination
of a very close friendship
between two girls.
I put in a lot of my
personal experiences
going to school in
India in there as well.
It's inspired a lot by my own
relationship with authority.
A lot of my work stems from
the idea of individuality
and the cost that comes
with it, especially
in like traditional societies.
Winning a Student Academy
Award means everything
really at this
point in my career.
I think the validation
is very important.
Romantically, any film
maker anywhere in the world
would love to be
recognized by the Academy.
It, kind of, puts a
lot of life and energy
into what you really
need to keep going.
I'd like to thank my
amazing, strong, wonderfully
strange family back home in
India who are responsible
for me being here today.
I'd never made a film before
going into the NYU Grad Film
Program.
And I learned it
all from my friends.
So I'd like to thank
each and every person
on the team of Bittu.
Your work has
transformed the movie.
Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
You've won the gold.
Gold is the top prize.
Spike Lee told me
that we got gold.
That Umama--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
It's a story that a
lot of South Africans
can relate to from different
perspectives within the film.
And I think it's important
for South Africans
to be able to see
themselves but also to see
the other people who they
have relationships with
and see their perspectives.
Thank you so much
to the Academy.
You made the dreams of
a little 8-year-old girl
from South Africa come true.
Just to be nominated
is phenomenal.
Why am I crying?
Thank you, NYU, for
championing this film.
My incredible producing
team, my incredible cast
I feel like the film gods
have put you on this earth
to be in this film.
I'm standing here as a
really proud South African.
Because I know that this is
a validation to us all that
our stories have a
place to be told.
And we can tell them.
Thank you.
Under one hour, huh?
Maybe they should have
me host the Oscars.
Well, what a night
this has been,
watching the look of pure joy
on the faces of our winners
as the legends they look up
to, share the incredible news
that so much hard
work has paid off.
It's just, you know, it's the
look of determination rewarded
and congratulations
delivered by the very best
in the field to the
best yet to come.
All those late nights,
so many dreams,
and so much daring,
and so much hope
reaffirmed and renewed about
the promise and potential
that stretches out still ahead.
Admittedly, 2020 has given
us all reason to drink.
Right?
But tonight, tonight has given
us reason to lift the glass
and raise a toast.
To the time when we can
all be together again
in person, to big dreams,
and to a hopeful tomorrow.
Cheers.
Buena noches.
Y buena suerte.
This is water.
Come on.